subcommittee once I get my proper gavel
so do we have
yeah what order are we going in so it's
not necessarily my order right okay so
yeah do we have so that's yours yeah
that was right you took it from the
calendar
this is yeah no it's it's YouTube
everything we everything we do or say is
preserved forever
okay
6 13 is that our first one
all right
where is my 613. okay though this is
this is when we want to pass okay
uh do we have any amendments insurance
department
look at all these people here okay
we're all good
we're all good okay and uh who is who
are the sponsors
okay okay
there you go okay
okay uh so um I'll move and
representative Burroughs will second
uh ought to pass on House Bill 613 is
there any discussion on the motion
okay seeing none this is the insurance
committee so this is
Terry is still missing
post
purcelli
purcelli's missing too right
yeah right right okay myself
collabro
and Vincent he's missing too
and
it gives
us here yeah I appreciate that
okay so this this is this is okay all
right
uh well it seems that we are missing
three people
am I getting that right
yeah exactly all right so at this point
yeah
we we may need a sub but at this point
um let's let's hopefully we won't need
one right
hope to see how we do here okay uh so uh
all those in favor of
ought to pass on 613 raise your hand one
two three but you're not on one two
three four
and five okay
all right
if I just zip
okay
all right what's that oh here we go okay
so 303 is next
relative insurance coverage for Pain
Management Services okay 303 we have
already taken taken up retained seven
zip so we're all set with that
next is four one four P fast coverages
okay so this one we have we were mailed
out the codes
and whether the codes work or not I
think is best for us to retain this bill
so we can find out whether these codes
are working or not and if there's not
then we'll have to revisit the issue
come September
okay I agree I just I just like to
comment that
um a um
an administrative health expert looked
at the codes and said they're absolutely
not comprehensive
not comprehensive not comprehensive
exactly there still could be some
there's something in there but it
doesn't cover everything that we needed
to cover so no obviously we don't have
your
consultant here with us today but I
could get them here pretty soon
so the question I have is and I've
always wondered about that when it comes
to these codes is that
um
if a physician
thinks getting tested is a good idea
and and you're saying not comprehensive
but theoretically it's sort of a grab
bag they could choose any one of those
not necessarily like he gave me an
example of if you have a heart condition
that might have been precipitated by P
fast's contamination it would not be
covered is what he said interest so
there is a possibility that it could get
rejected yes okay so uh
I I know I it went many many moons ago I
passed external review
would someone if uh got a uh if a
physician put in a code and it wasn't
comprehensive or some would external
review kick in and would there be an
opportunity to revisit that
do you mind coming up to the mic sorry
because we want to preserve what you
have to say forever and ever
thank you chairman hunt I think there
are a couple things that would come into
play here one the health condition would
be covered on its own whether it's pfas
related or not and secondarily if a code
isn't isn't entirely comprehensive there
is an external review process there's
also a process to work with the
providers and get your Priuses necessary
uh we have a team in our department that
if there's somebody who doesn't feel
like it's being approved appropriately
we can work them walk them through that
process I know that you've had Keith
nyan's number here before but I think
the coverage already exists and as as
kind of medical appreciation for how to
best treat it changes
codes will change and the way they're
approved will change
um I don't think uh from the
Department's point of view there needs
to be a change today we don't have a
complaint that we're sitting on saying
we haven't been able to get somebody
coverage okay
yeah go ahead
we had a um the person that submitted
the bill had an issue so that's why this
bill is here
I'm not suggesting that nobody has had a
complaint I'm saying the insurance
department has never had a complaint I
would encourage that person if somebody
thought they had an issue I would
encourage them to talk to our experts so
that we can interface with the insurance
company and ensure that it's coverage
and the external review process is a
determination of medical necessity and
that's where it would happen and so
there are teams internal and external to
the department that would help with
those
okay thank you all right
so uh
I move and
representative Burrough seconds to
retain House Bill 414 any discussion on
the motion
all those in favor raise your hand
one two three four five
okay
beautiful okay
three one nine establishing committee to
study an all-pair system of insurance
for Hospital services
okay so theoretically we we passed this
one
and then uh representative Terry did
tell me that he he looked into
Pennsylvania law and they hadn't passed
it the only state that actually did pay
up as a pastor has it in place is
Maryland and evidently Maryland has had
it in place for for years and years and
they have Revisited many times so
basically it's just this the Maryland
statute excuse about Maryland
um my consultant consultant my husband
if you're being a transparent said that
the Maryland all-payer system isn't
isn't a bona fide all-pair system he
said it's different so if um
representative Terry has his committee
this summer we could get more info on
that right so I guess I I thought all
pair was kind of a misleading what it's
what it sounded like to me in the
testimony was that
um the what the hospital would be
reimbursed was pre was determined not
through a contractual arrangement with
insurance companies as we do it now
we're the rest of us states do it is
instead it was predetermined by a state
agency
I can't go deeper than that is that it
correct there was a state bureaucrat
what was it was it done through the
Maryland insurance department or who was
the who was the one of determining the
reimbursement rates
I'm looking I'm not looking at you Paula
not this time
okay why don't you take a seat
good morning Paula Rogers and I'm here
on behalf of Anthem this morning and
there may be people in the audience that
know far more about this than I but in a
conversation I did have with the chair
earlier we talked about Maryland in
general and my understanding is Maryland
had a unique situation that sort of came
forth in 1970 or thereabouts and it sort
of uh sort of got control of an
all-payer system with some sort of
commission-like body and it included
Medicaid reimbursement it included
Medicare which is pretty unusual and the
private insurers and that system sort of
went along very productively from
Maryland's point of view for a number of
decades I do believe something happened
four or five years ago whether they sort
of converted it into a slightly
different model but the same concept it
was hospital-based services and this
uniformity around reimbursements that
came from all the payers for a
particular procedure and my
understanding is many people feel that
this has held rates down but it has not
addressed utilization so there's this
human nature sort of thing where if you
have a fixed rate and in the old days
you used to be able to negotiate that
rate on your own
um if the rate is fixed there's this
sort of pressure saying all right we
feel maybe this isn't enough how are we
going to address utilization and expand
that so there's sort of that perverse
concept that's in the background that
people don't address very directly so
that's if they've got if they if there
is this still in place then they must
have gotten a waiver a Medicare waiver
they they arranged with Medicare way
back in the 70s Medicare you guys are
waiting so it was a unique situation
they were grandfather did right other
states have tried to put some sort of
modification in with
um sort of a percentage Tolerance on
rate increases carrier to carrier so
everybody struggles with this but and
it's a complex issue and each state of
course has a different sort of geography
to it as far as the payers that are in
the system which makes it complicated so
um is is Anthem in Maryland
Sabrina Dunlop is here Maryland as far
as I remember is not in the commercial
Market except it's let's put it this way
it's not in the probably individual and
Exchange Market we have here it would be
in the commercial Market okay so of our
other providers is ensure if any of them
actually in the Maryland Market
I mean I I'm thinking about if we're
going to bring consultants and experts
on this
Hoover it would be nice to have someone
in state who's actually right you
wouldn't you want to have somebody that
is has been in that Maryland system and
I'm sure Anthem has some exposure in
Maryland okay and I'm sure Cigna would
have some exposure in Maryland so you're
talking about the big National Carriers
okay all right now I have a card here
from Laura Cooley
okay so just so you understand Laura
this is a subcommittee so you will not
be testifying okay but if you would want
to come in and uh say something or two
and be willing to take questions and
then we will certainly invite you up yes
this is your moment
thank you my name is Laura Cooley and I
live in Orford New Hampshire I moved up
here in 2001 so I've been here for 21
years
um I'm an acupuncturist I had chronic
pain for 17 years I have three major
instabilities in my spine and for 15
years I tried to get some kind of help
for pain nothing helps me yeah we get
the right Bill 303. oh yeah okay I'm
sorry sorry we're all set on three I
know okay I thought you were talking
about this bill no that's why I was
leaving because I realized no you're
done okay thank you thank you all right
sorry okay
um
representative Terry you're not excited
about uh researching this this uh what
Marilyn does and see whether it be a
good thing to to do in New Hampshire you
were
my mother always told me that I should
answer a question the way that it was
put to me in which case Mr chairman I
would have to say uh uh I am intrigued
by this however
uh since you threatened me
with uh the chairmanship of this uh this
study committee I decided that it would
be important for me to do some
additional research to see what I might
be getting myself into and when I did
that as the chairman knows from my
correspondence with him within the last
48 hours I found that there were more
questions that were being raised uh and
so um I I shifted my position as the
chairman knows and now all of you will
know from ought to pass to retain I
think it's an intriguing idea but it's a
exceedingly complex subject and I think
that it's it would be premature in in my
view to uh to take this step of setting
up a study committee at this time
and and just a site is another example
um I believed in testimony that we heard
that there were other states that had
adopted such a system and one of the
states that was cited was Pennsylvania
so I did an extensive internet surge for
information uh with respect to the
passage of such a system in Pennsylvania
and couldn't find anything
furthermore I couldn't find anything
about an all-payer or single pay or
whatever system in in Pennsylvania
furthermore the the language of the of
the bill
requires that the governor
appoint
an expert
who resides in New Hampshire an expert
on the Maryland system and I thought it
was rather curious that we're this far
along in the process of considering this
bill and we have absolutely no idea
whether such a person even exists
so I I think that this this bill begs
for a lot more work and that's why I
would move my position from otps I had
expressed earlier irrespective of the
threat of the chairperson I think on the
merits uh this this bill needs to be
retained and the threat still continues
if we retain it I will still put you in
charge of the which case I will have to
think about this over lunch in which
case it would be too late so I uh so in
terms of retaining it we would just it
the difference from yes the bill as it's
written which is not with anything it's
got uh
one person from the Senate and three
house members one oh just one one and
one which I pointed out this is uh no no
four members of the House
and one in the Senate four members of
the house so it's all sense of purposes
it's it wouldn't be not much different
than retaining except it then has all
these other people who uh which shall be
solicited which can still be solicited
if we retained it so retaining is not a
bad idea I think they have a lot more
work to do to satisfy me well it's this
bills
vetting by this committee uh has not
reached a us a level at which I am
confident in being able to vote one way
or the other up or down
um and so if I was pushed I would have
to say
um I would vote in expedient to
legislate between ITP and OTP because
itl and OTP uh because it can always
come back in the future
so the question for me is is it worthy
of work at this time
but by this committee or uh do we just
say no and ask the the the sponsors to
uh to do some more work on this before
they bring it back in a couple of years
all right so that that's the question
okay that's my conundrum yeah yeah I
guess I um given that the awkwardness of
the situation here where we actually
took action to pass it
um I'd be more
inclined to know I'm going to be looking
at my leadership in order to leadership
I'd be more inclined to retain it and
then I will personally take charge of
finding someone who is an expert on
Maryland to come in and testify to the
committee
and I'll say I'll I'll sounds like a
plan discharge you from that
responsibility thank you so because I'd
be interested to hear what they did I
appreciate being discharged rather than
jettisoned
thank you for your choice of words
yes thank you okay so are you are we
comfortable to revisit this and and then
retain it
okay
um so I guess to to go through proper
parliamentary well uh um I moved to
reconsider our actions
um on uh the subcommittee's actions on
um and I asked urge everyone to vote Yes
so all those in favor of reconsidering
our action
um on 319 please raise your hand
one two three four
six okay and then I moved that we
retained this bill
all those a favor
in two three four five six okay
okay
353 it sounds interesting Commerce
and we've already retained this okay
it's already been retained beautiful
and we've already retained it
I'm sorry that I I just had the wrong
list in front of me and I was
so busy trying to make the list of what
needed to be taking up and I
didn't pay attention to do my homework
okay so the next one is
389 we actually already voted to retain
it
okay hb130 now that one I do have an
amendment for
excuse me what did we do with 353
we that was retained earlier okay
foreign
okay
right on this plug
yes okay
um
so we'll hold this off into while you go
okay
um
I I I I I do 25 no
so um just I'll briefly describe what
the situation is this was the the PBM
uh study and um affordability I guess
it's technically a drug affordability
board
um now I'm not sure everybody heard
about that the um the rules committee
did you hear about what happened in
rules committee okay so yeah this I
guess it had I was I on were we on
vacation did this happen last week or I
guess it was just after we left but
anyways the rules committee
um got bogged down on
um the funding problem
because the way the bill was written it
was an assessment the fee assessment and
um and they have just had
ruled that that was not not really a fee
that was an inappropriate assessment
system
um and so that the the right way to do
it is it needs to be paid for out of
General funds
the governor does have some money in it
in his budget I'm told
I don't know if that's anybody here can
confirm or not confirm that for me but
so TJ okay so that so there is money in
there so the question is we need to fix
the statute to a
um which I think it would is that in
House Bill two of you guys is that the
language maybe in the house bill too
wouldn't it
so it theoretically so there was two
parts one the one part was that and then
the other part was the penalties
the the issue has penalties in it which
it was giving uh an inappropriate board
a kind of a penalty system so the
amendment that I have is a is to turn it
into a that it could be General the
money will come from General funds or
from contributions because clearly uh
new Futures and ARP there were people
who are interested in this study so you
know that that they might be able to
find some money to help the study and
then B was just to remove the penalties
so a wait till I had the amendment and
we'll take it up at that time I just
want to say I'm I've been in contact
with the sponsors and they um
they're not comfortable with that
Amendment they would like to retain it
to review alternative funding sources
they're not completely comfortable with
the idea of it coming from General funds
or at all possibly because they're
concerned that they'll you know how how
long are they going to be funded
oh okay well I'll be the next two years
to buy any of them okay they would like
you know they would like to retain it so
that they have time to really do some
more work on the only concern with that
is that means
okay that one means that if there was
money in the budget and did get it would
have to be then be in the trailer house
bill too
you really want to vote for Hospital too
um no I'd like to see your Amendment and
uh okay possibly phone a friend okay
perfect all right so we'll wait till we
get that we'll come back to that one
okay
at this moment we're gonna We're Not
Gonna Take It Up until until we we have
this amendment and we can think about it
but we we have just so everybody knows
we we technically we do have an exact
session this afternoon we don't have to
take up everything this afternoon and
then we have
um uh next week
and uh it can't be Tuesday because
Tuesday is home meeting day so I would
be doing everything on Wednesday so
anything that's left over from what we
do uh this afternoon uh we would
schedule for a subcommittee in the
morning of Wednesday and then exec it
Wednesday afternoon and and have to have
it done
because a I don't want to come back on
Thursday but if we have to we would come
back on Thursday but we wouldn't want to
get everything done next week but we'll
we're my my expectation is is we're
going to try to get through everything
today in the afternoon in terms of
executing for but I know there's at
least one bill and that's uh Keith
so we're still that those are still have
to be uh addressed that we're gonna have
to put that off till uh Wednesday next
week anyways
okay
so do you wanna
you wanna sit on this for a moment yeah
okay fine all right no problem All Right
Moving On 172.
has already been retained 7-0
383 relative to provider contract
standards for pharmacy benefit managers
383.
we've actually retained this already
okay
next is 4 26.
the pharmacists in charge
so 383 was retained
okay 426.
um I I have that we want to pass this
okay is there any Amendment whose bills
whose businesses
right right is rofford okay does anybody
have a problem with passing 426. Speak
now or forevermore hold your peace
okay good
um
TP
uh who like to move this one forward
okay representative spear well no you
can't you could but I'll do it for now
and then you can do it later
okay collabro collabro wants to do it
great representative collabro second in
uh by myself
um moose uh OTP on 426. is there any
discussion on the motion see none all
those in favor please raise your hand
two three four five six
all right six zip
okay
this is perfect because we have one on
each side is missing so this is pairing
okay
all right next is
5 30 ml to 4 billion safety of
clinically administered drugs
okay I think I have an amendment on this
one right
John I have a question okay
okay actually yeah so we're here we're
still we're still waiting for
legislative Services Chris
oh wait a minute yeah 513 yeah the one
we just sent this morning
okay all right so for the committee
members yeah
based on what we heard in the hearing
we have
one set of people that can get the drug
get their uh medication they Infuse
medication at a clinic or a hospital and
the insurance companies will pay for it
but depending on their coverage
they that we ask the insurance company
specifically do they have a problem with
the rate and they said no
we were told that the rate was higher
and maybe as much as four times higher
than what it would be if they had
the medication delivered to the patient
and then the patient brought it in
that is referred to as brown bagging so
I don't want to have to keep saying that
over and over again
the other class of people a group of
people were people who are
receiving the medication at home
and they're bringing it to the clinic
they pay the insurance company pays a
lower rate for that situation
we have a situation in the and and
people have been doing this apparently
for years
and thank you and the delivery of the
medication to the individual is often
the same delivery system as delivery I
mean by like mail I don't I don't mean
injection the uh the supply delivery is
the same delivery as the people in the
hospitals they're getting it through the
same delivery system
so what we're seeing essentially is
a medication that can be delivered two
different ways one of which is cheaper
than the other
and that the insurance company is okay
with either delivery now here's my
question
we have a about a 20 underinsurance rate
in this state that's about 20 percent of
the people who are between uh 18 and 65
that are hanging on by a thread with the
amount of insurance that they get that
they can afford to buy
those people
if they are not allowed to Brown Bag
their medication they won't get the
medication
the people who can afford or have access
to the insurance where the hospitals are
getting more money
is actually a help for the hospitals the
patient is getting what they want and
the hospitals are getting a small
subsidy and we know that in New
Hampshire especially up in the northern
part of the state our hospitals are
totally beleaguered we're losing
hospitals they're consolidating we're
losing services
so the fact that this is an agreed to
plan to help them out a little bit
doesn't seem that it hurts anybody so
here's my question
who is benefiting from this bill
it isn't either of these two groups it
isn't the patience on either side who
benefits from this bill
okay so
um what we have in front of you
is the amendment that representative
you've brought in with a little bit of a
little bit of changes
and um I would say the the biggest
benefit was actually in his original
language which is that the reimbursement
rate will be at what the insurance
company normally reimburses if it was
directly purchased through let's say a
pharmacist so that will save all rate
payers all rate pairs just time me out
will save all rate payers because now
the insurance companies won't have to
pay out as much to the hospitals so
that's in that's in that in Roman
numeral too Roman numeral three
if you look at it and see how it's
written a patient may opt in
a program by which and is the health
organ that's your brown bag right there
so basically to answer your question is
who will benefit from this
everybody is going to benefit by passing
this I'm sorry I'm not naive I do not
believe that for a second but as long as
they allow it to be opt in
I can live with that good I can't I
don't ever believe that in my lifetime
and I'm old and I'm older than you are I
have never ever seen insurance rates go
down not ever okay so
um
guaranteeing that insurance rates would
go down would would be a very dangerous
premise for me or anybody to ever say
that okay what I do know
is that we have a a law
uh that was a part of the Affordable
Care Act
and which is called the minimum loss
ratio
and which basically says that a premium
is determined by how much the insurance
company pays out
okay and uh so therefore if the
insurance company can pay less
than it will have an impact on that
minimum loss ratio and not saying that
notwithstanding other factors
other new pharmaceutical other new
cancer patient medicines that might come
out but in this case at least we have
addressed that problem of that the
hospitals were billing for these cancer
medications at a rate that was four
times higher than what would be paid if
there was a brown bag option available
so the hospitals themselves though are
still gonna I I can't read this thing
fast enough I'm sorry
this amendment was actually was in the
hearing was then where when we had the
hearing on this bill
everything you see in here in that case
I didn't see
you're right I did okay I understand
representative Gibbs
um
just to be sure
um this amendment has been reviewed by
the sponsor and the sponsor is okay with
it
uh
okay anybody other uh we're we're he's
getting it we're getting it to him oh
standby okay sorry
okay any other questions anybody have
okay go ahead
something was said that I I um take
umbrance with
um there are people with the ages of six
18 to 99 essentially who are able to
without insurance without any insurance
to go to a federally subsidized Clinic
an hrsa and get medications they are
pharmacies within those clinics that
will reduce the price of those they are
federally subsidized to be able to do so
I've never seen anybody paying more than
a hundred and fifty dollars for a large
um for a large
Specialty Pharmacy drug because of that
okay so there are places for them I
would tell you that I am one last
provider in those clinics so and they
are leaving like like everywhere but
there is a place for them to go
good
what yes oh the hospital Association
might want to weigh in yes come on up
I'm sure you had did you get a copy yet
have you got an account
okay we don't have a formal copy yet
for the record my name is Kathy Bazar
with umberg Executive Vice President New
Hampshire Hospital Association
representing all the hospitals in New
Hampshire thank you for the opportunity
to speak to this work session on House
Bill 513. we do have concerns with this
bill and the amendment when we came and
testified we had just been handed the
amendment so we didn't have a chance to
review we've had a chance to review and
we still have concerns and in fact we
believe that this bill is not ready for
prime time there are many complexities
to this particular topic and in fact the
sponsor had said that his bill addressed
both white bagging and brown bagging
when he testified on the bill and we
don't believe that the bill covers white
bagging at all I think the language in
here is only Brown bagging the sponsor
also said that his language moves the
practice
of the payments to a pharmacy benefit
again the language in this bill is not
clear at all that that is true
um so we believe that if it does go to a
pharmacy benefit the people who will be
impacted will be the patients themselves
typically Pharmacy benefits have a lot
less coverage from medications and so
they have high deductibles and high
co-pays so the person who's paying more
out of pocket will be the patient
um and then lastly it only amends the
Managed Care statute there are other
insurance statutes that are not
contemplated in this bill so we think
there could be some loopholes here with
the consideration of this particular
topic
um also for for clarification on um I
think representative you had questions
about Brown bagging web bagging and how
that actually works so both those
practices are insurance company required
practices so it comes from them
they're the ones who are going to be
benefiting financially because most of
the specialty pharmacies that they
require to be used are their own
specialty pharmacies so they're paying
themselves
so that's where the money is coming from
so I just want to make sure that that
was clear to the committee and for all
those reasons we believe that this bill
because of those complexities and not
having a full view of the particular
issues at hand that we believe this bill
should be itl'd or at a minimum retained
so uh I'm teaching by your concept that
that if you move from the hospital
benefit to the pharmaceutical benefit
that there is a potential that the
patient would have to pay more out of
pocket correct
and but then again that really is
determined by whatever health insurance
plan they happen to have right but
knowing how the insurance industry is
going most of the uh Pharmacy benefits
are pretty minimal for some of them and
um I think there should be a really uh
in-depth review of Pharmacy benefits to
ensure that the patient is not Health
harm you know harmed in this practice so
um would you agree with me that the the
insurance department should be able to
evaluate that to like do a fiscal note
to see whether that be true yes okay
could the insurance department do a
physical review within a week
okay so we'll take this amendment up
next week thank you
that agreeable to everybody
okay
uh as soon as we get it for you you're
right
okay so we are leaving that to
Gene
okay
uh okay 479.
okay this is another insurance
department and we all know amendments
this is a clean
insurance department you're all set with
this one
don't right so we're all set as it is
there
oh so we have an amendment in front of
us wait did we have a do we
oh this was it introduced after hearing
so it is the yeah is it uh this is Will
infantine Amendment
okay all right so uh first we'll discuss
uh this amendment which I guess was
handed out at the hearing
and um
so I'll move and
representative Rose will second the
amendment uh is there any discussion on
this amendment
excuse me this is the get rid of the
website today you're there yeah uh
and it was handed out at the hearing and
the reason
okay could you just refresh my memory as
to why
so do you mind come on come on down
good morning I'm Heather Silverstein
general counsel of the insurance
department
um
this amendment was brought forward after
having discussion with industry and the
this is the part of the bill that dealt
with our Administration fund and we send
bills that basically fund our department
as part of the administration fund to
our licensees and uh the original Bill
had
um us either posting on the website as a
way to provide notice for the billing or
by email to the email that the insurer
had provided the department after having
discussion with industry
um we agreed that it's not fair to have
a posting on the website and it's more
direct and more fair to our licensees to
have it just be the email notice and so
that's all this amendment is pertaining
to
but come
would you like
we can have copies made okay so Mr
chairman now that I uh thank you for
refreshing my memory
um
it almost because I support this it
almost becomes a mood point
to ask why it was there in the first
place it seems inappropriate that it
would have been on the website for the
whole world to see when it's actually a
party that owes a certain amount of
money you're going to notify that person
personally through email so we're fine
that's that's good yes yes that's how
that's right to save time I'm not going
to even ask you why what the thinking
was in posting it on the website so
that's not a question thank you
thank you
okay
all right because we're all set thank
you
so we'll wait to take action on that
well
okay all right so um I moved up we uh
approve the amendment number 206 H 206 H
okay any discussion on the motion about
to pass on the amendment seeing none all
those in favor please raise your hand
two three four five six
okay and uh I move
to pass as amended
represent Burrows all those any
discussion
okay none all those in favor raise your
hand two three four five six
okay
uh
that was 479 uh
the next one is 210 relative to fire
insurance contracts
okay
all right everybody's okay with this one
right
we're all good yeah
no amendments
okay
uh so I will move representative Rose uh
second ought to pass on House Bill 210.
any discussion on the motion
all those in favor raise your hand
two three four five six
okay
[Music]
two
Forty Nine
uh establishing regulatory standards for
pet insurance industry okay
so we have an amendment
on this bill
and to make sure we have the right
amendment number right
um
so just another Community I I've been
trying to do some research on what
happened last year and we and we're
scratching our heads we have no idea how
this one slipped through the cracks how
the mistake get done in the first place
I can only imagine uh it's one of those
Classics that
um
communist communication with legislative
services and
yeah
much like
no it doesn't resolve it but just say
that's why in the first time why what
happened last year why why they replaced
this language in the statute why they
didn't do a Roman numeral three back
then
um but at least we will get an
opportunity to fix it and it turns out
that the Manchester's
uh enforce the uh their what it was the
health department actually follows the
statute and that's really how we how the
state statute so ironically no it wasn't
the actual sponsor having a problem but
then he doesn't have anybody inspecting
he doesn't have a state expecting his
facility anyways but that it was ironic
that a city a city discovered the
mistake so but at least we get it fixed
now all right so we have an amendment
number yeah
each
okay seven
okay
so I move and seconded by represent
below no that's right you're not on the
committee right yeah can I just ask a
question yes um I just want to make sure
the insurance uh department is okay with
the amendment on this one
they want to pass the bill
in terms of not jeopardizing the pet
insurance piece of it
well I'll let you know about that after
you all vote
if you all vote for it then I think
we're in pretty good shape but if
there's dissent
um then obviously that makes me a little
nervous but in all honesty I mean we
don't have a position but but I sat in
on your discussion
uh yesterday and it seems to me as
though what you're doing is bringing
back a statute that seemed to perform
very well for a number of years
so that wouldn't strike me as being
necessarily controversial for anyone but
that is my opinion as a former
legislator and not necessarily with the
insurance department so I think I think
we're happy
okay any other questions thank you
okay so uh all those in favor of the
amendment uh please raise your hands one
two three four five
six
six zero
okay
and uh the underlying Bill there was no
need to change that since it was model
legislation right we're all set with
that so uh all those in favor uh passing
249 as uh to pass as a men did please
raise your hand
two three or five six zip
okay
oh sorry
um
so we're just down to the last one 304.
yes
all right so 304
um
this was the uh
proactively educating
[Music]
people is that what I would call this
is though you can watch consumer
protection but you know I was thinking
somebody who uh I just happened to
notice he has a truck that has the check
engine light on
and I asked him I said well why haven't
you had that fixed and he said well I
did and they said it was some one of
those electronic things and it would
cost him two thousand dollars to fix it
and that he didn't really
want to fix it for two thousand dollars
so the question is notwithstanding your
bill which is that you're trying to
educate a consumer by rsas which I'm
sure consumers I'm not really reading
our statutes that closely but that what
happens if someone really didn't
you know one of the cheap windshields he
was an old car one of the Jeep you would
chill and knew that they were losing out
on the backup feature or the or the you
know the safety features that that that
glass had
would shouldn't they be allowed to make
that decision on their own should they
be able to
say I don't need to do it yeah
thank you Mr chairman yeah of course and
you know for my four years on this
committee that I don't believe in
legislating common sense in most cases
so I completely agree with you they
should be and this bill allows for that
but it also allows for a tiny bit of
Education like representative Spears
pointed out most people like I was had
no idea that they could be incurring a
pretty huge cost and a pretty dangerous
situation with loss of their Collision
sensors and their radar sensors and all
the other things
um after the public hearing I got
flooded with emails and I'm guessing
some of this committee did too
because a number of different online
places picked up on this bill being in
front of this committee
glass bite and various Auto Collision
Rags around the the country and said you
know we're glad it's being addressed
[Music]
um
so I was surprised at how many other
people and Industry places were were
happy at reputable repair places were
happy that we were considering this
little bit of notification and I mean
you know my general political philosophy
that I don't go looking for problems to
solve they're doing just fine or
unnecessary
consumer protection or I mean I
generally believe in you know buyer
beware and do your research and things
like that because I do it myself
and this came as a complete surprise and
when I was approached about sponsoring
this legislation it wasn't front of mind
I was I didn't sponsor this legislation
because I had a glass crack and I
thought oh we need a bill because of
this
somebody came to me and said
there's an industry issue here and I
happen to have already experienced it
and I thought
wow this this really actually is a
problem I didn't realize how big of a
problem it was I did go through it
myself so the two came together and
that's how the legislation came
to the committee right and then even
more came out so
so that's the but a little bit when you
talk to your insurance company they did
tell you by the way that make sure you
get the right glass my particular
insurance company as I mentioned it
happened to be Geico and I found out
later that some of the big ones like
Progressive said we require in order for
you to be in Reverse by us that you use
the right kind of repair shop
so they did but plenty of people pay out
of pocket for something like a glass
repair
and so they go looking around for the
cheapest provider and some glass repairs
can be done very inexpensively as I'm
sure you know it's it's a it can be
almost a commodity surface a service
but these days there's what I discovered
was there's a lot more to it I mean if
you have an old clunker you have an
older vehicle it doesn't have all those
sensors it's not that big of a deal but
it's a safety it's just what I
discovered was it's a safety factor in
cars after a certain year and I forgive
me I don't remember exactly what year
but it's
it's I think it's fairly recent I'm sure
and there's an expert here that probably
could tell us or somebody may remember
from testimony
so for me it was a it's a safety factor
and you know I'm a 30-year paramedic and
I've seen an awful lot of bad window uh
you know bad accidents and things so and
we you know we're all at times in
attentive drivers and I've
I've heard those alarms go off and I'm
pretty glad they're there pretty glad I
have those sensors probably won't buy a
car again that doesn't have them and
I'll probably make sure my glass gets
calibrated if I get another window chip
so don't think it's a bad Bill don't
think it's harming anybody I don't think
it's unnecessary regulation
I'll be happy if it saves one or two
lives if somebody gets their window
calibrated when otherwise they might not
have
the consumer protection act is um
generally is designed to make the
consumer whole with they've been harmed
so the question is is there anyone out
there illegally
putting it or it you know fraudulently
installing the wrong glass
and then once a consumer finds out that
they had the wrong glass installed does
not make the consumer whole by replacing
it with the proper one no I I don't
think there is to be honest with you I
mean I don't know I haven't done that
research but I don't I don't think so I
think what this bill does it just
directs them I think they're going to
get
good glass installed and I think this
bill is designed my intent for the bill
is that they would then get directed to
somebody with the proper calibration so
you can have the mama pop or the or the
less capable Glass Service install your
glass but then you're told you're told
ideally up front
hey we'll do your glass but you have to
go do part two or you should go do part
two you can neglect to do that you don't
have you can ignore them and say I'm
fine with my sensors not working like
you said that's your free choice take
the discount glass job save a few
pennies but understand that all your
stuff doesn't work now
your heads up display is not going to
work your inflation warning all the
stuff's not going to work your lane
keeping all that stuff
and save the money but what you what we
just want to let you know that it's not
going to work so don't come back to us
because a we we can't fix it even if we
wanted to but at least here's a list of
people it doesn't even matter yeah okay
yeah so representative spear you I'd
like to yeah weigh in on this
I I've looked into this as you know yeah
we had a lot of conversation and
unbelievable research one other thing in
that way that I have one of the things I
found was that new cars today don't come
with uh operators manuals anymore
they're built into their uh electronic
systems you know you have to look them
up on your little car dashboard
so my car being 13 years old I had one
so I saw what I had what had to be
calibrated
but what I also found was that there's a
whole lot of other things that can cause
those cameras to get misaligned the
camera is built into the rear part of
the rear view mirror up at the top it's
not part of the glass as part of the
rear view mirror
if that gets jostled it's going to be
out of sync right it's not going to see
the little dots in the right place where
it's supposed to see them
so replacing the glass certainly moves
it around
but so does a wheel alignment so does
hitting a curb
there's a lot of things so if we're
going to do this if we do this bill I
think it's got to be a little broader
because it's going to be a laundry list
of things that need to be there's a
laundry list of things that can cause
this camera to get out of adjustment
it's the glass certainly
but it's not the only thing the
recommendation in a Ford
the brand new Ford Mustang said that you
got to check it if even if you uh
replace your tires
so
while I think we should do something
maybe
I think it's got to be broader because
it's not covering the whole issue and
unfortunately people don't sit in their
cars and read their Little Manuals I
probably would but you know other people
wouldn't
you like manuals so Mr Mr chairman some
other states had much broader bills and
they were difficult to implement and
difficult for the collision repair shops
to to deal with this is a simplified
version that just notifies the consumer
makes them aware of the issue and lets
the consumer it's the New Hampshire way
to implement this
I think right it's a it's a notification
it makes consumer aware in your opinion
in my in my in my opinion and I think
it's shared by okay the spirit of the
committee I don't have a problem with
limiting it but I just wanted
I'm less inclined to get too excited
about this bill I mean it's just simply
it may not understanding that it now
opens up this opportunity for everyone
to come in and every little issue when
it comes to saying you know boy that I
don't see it no problem
someone who's been spent uh the consumer
protection act you know have been on
this committee all these years and being
part of the I have just I'm so wedded to
this you know what what the purpose of
this act it it seems it seems to be a
little awkward to be adding this to the
list but I don't see it as a slippery
slope I'm not really excited about it so
if you wanted to retain it so that we
could add more items to it or and you're
saying no don't do that so yeah
representative Terry
um Mr chairman you mentioned um
under the consumer protection act which
you're citing
um in reference to this yeah the
requirements of this bill
um fraud
so I'm wondering that the way things
stand now how there could possibly be
fraud
a consumer goes in and gets a windshield
replacement
and the the repair shop puts in a
different windshield the one that
doesn't have all the bells and whistles
right
because that's what the the the the the
owner of the vehicle was quoted
so how did that become fraudulent how is
how could that possibly
there is no fraud so the consumer
protection that covers fraud doesn't
apply here because there's no fraud
however if you have this Statute in
place and that were to happen then there
would be a violation of law
correct so representative Cherry thanks
for bringing it up I'm not an attorney
nor do I work in the you know Consumer
Protection Bureau but in my opinion
separately as a consumer the only time
that I would perceive it as fraud is if
they told me you're going to have a
fully functional
windshield with all your sensors and I
for somehow somehow they made me believe
that
you know and then I didn't
but I think that's another reason to
pass this bill because this prevents
that this discloses that you're going to
get your car back with a working
windshield the way you had it when you
brought it in and I think most
reasonable consumers most prudent men
would think they were going to get their
car back working the way they brought it
in because most consumers don't realize
how sophisticated their windshields are
these days that's the point that's the
way I was like here's what you're
missing
the consumer protection act would only
really kick in
is if the guy the the window repair guy
the guy who put it in
who gave you misinformation
refuses to put the Right One In
other words the consumer protection is
to make you whole exactly myself so
therefore if that if the and that to me
is fraud and that's already in the
consumer protection Mr chairman that's
exactly my point we want to keep those
little guys in New Hampshire in business
we want to make it so that they can
repair
and do their business in New Hampshire
on these sophisticated Windows because
right now it's difficult for them to
compete right we want to we want to make
it so they can compete with the big guys
they can still do the do the glass
without having Grandma and Grandpa come
back and say hey
you ruin my windshield and now you can't
fix it because they don't have the
capability of doing it so so then they
have to just give you your money back
correct as long as you give you your
money back in your own set do you want
to put the mom and pop glass shops in
that position of giving the money back I
would hope the Mom and Pop Shop did
don't uh you have not convinced me that
Mom and Pop shops actually do that I
don't I have not been convinced that
there's actually a problem here yet
wouldn't it be better if they just told
the consumer up front we can do your
glass but we can't do your calibration
wouldn't that just be a simpler solution
I I hear where you're coming from so
thank you very much thank you very much
okay
um so I don't know how the other
committee members feel but I I I don't
want to pass this bill
so I mean I'll retain it if if you want
to continue the conversation but
otherwise I would just assume I would
make one comment
not that I'm allowed to vote but you
know what the heck
uh the problem is really the car
manufacturers themselves in reality we
can't do anything about them but that is
where the problem is I I hear you so
representative Gibbs what do you think
uh you'll be next here well I think that
this is a small problem perhaps and
there are bigger problems out there but
we bypassing this bill it sounds to me
that we would do something to help with
the small problem and therefore being a
member of the subcommittee I move out to
pass okay well let's we're right now
we're going to do a straw conversation
okay okay representative Terry
so on the question of misrepresentation
I I just need to help on thinking this
through so a so a a car owner goes to a
one shop and and gets gets a an estimate
of fifteen hundred dollars because it
includes all the bells and whistles this
is hypothetical then goes to a second
shop and the second shop says well
when we do develop this estimate it
needs to be the windshield that is the
original replacement has all the bells
and whistles that's you know fourteen
hundred and fifty dollars all right then
then uh the the cons the consumer the
owner of the vehicle goes to a third
shop and the third shop says
um we can do this for
um a thousand dollars
now the third shop
that the third shop is not going to
provide the windshield that has all the
bells and whistles but just a plain
windshield right
now the consumer doesn't ask any
questions looks at the three estimates
and says okay I'm going to go with one
for a thousand right I don't understand
how that becomes misrepresentation
because
there was no requirement
that the owner of that shop provide an
estimate that in that that supplied
original equipment shall we say
um
windshield as a replacement
correct okay so so that happens now so
that's Point number one point number two
is in the form of a question I'm trying
to remember anybody that was against
this
uh it seemed like even the everybody
that testified said
um we're fine with this we think this is
a good idea
so whenever I'm considering a piece of
legislation I'm wondering who's for it
and who's against it and right now other
than a philosophical if if I if I if I
may
characterize the the concern about this
this bill other than a philosophical
concern about not wanting to have yet
another statute on the books
um I'm not really hearing any
substantive
opposition
to the bill by any party concerned
what am I missing here except me
well I want to I don't want to
personalize this yeah well yeah well I
think it's philosophical I'm
philosophically opposed to doctor I'm
philosophically opposed to this bill
because I think it's prophylactic and
it's totally unnecessary and yes all the
people who want it are all auto glass
people who are doing it anyways so so I
mean the only time we pass legislations
we're trying to solve a problem that's
real that's not happening but we don't
we don't have any evidence that anybody
had the wrong windshield involved so if
if you if you had four children and all
four came to you and asked you for the
same thing and you said I don't believe
this is necessary
how do you think your four children
would feel I so we got we have a
constituency out there that says we
would like this and we're saying no
because we're philosophically opposed to
this uh so I've made up my mind I'm just
kind of give you an example I'll give
you an example what about your children
though because
example I'll give you is that
um
this committee has in the past years
have had legislation to license
home
Construction
contractors
and yes it's amazing how many
contractors come in and say that's a
great idea to license us
yeah okay and yet this committee's never
passed it
and why
because we know that it's going to mean
at the end of the day means that you
have limited the number of people who
are contractors you have now take and
you have no way to have the State
Licensing Bureau to ensure that the
contractor is actually competent
other than you've given them a license
and then you have John Hunt's rule of
licensure is the only reason we give you
a license and so we can take it away
when you've done something bad so I I
suggest the potential flaw in the
illustration that you've given us
might be that with respect to the
contractors you have a lot of mom and
pop type handy men and women
out there who do these sorts of things
and so if you were to require a license
in order for anybody to do any of this
you you certainly would be foreclosing
the the possibility that many would even
enter into the field of a handy person
all right okay that's so so it would be
uh prohibitive the legislation would
effect be prohibited and I am all I'm
saying is that I'm unaware uh I need to
be made aware of of repair shops that
that do glass replacement
that would effectively be uh driven out
of business if what everybody else is
asking for uh were to be placed in
statute if we were to try to pass
legislation for every time there's a
possibility that somebody could get the
wrong item
that statutes would we go forever I mean
it just it's innumerable let's just
stick to the problems that we have to
fix rather that's not create
I mean and it'll have unintended
consequences and I I just I don't feel
the compelling need for it I really
don't so in your view those who came and
testified in favor of this bill
already
a possible motive of these individuals
is to preempt others from entering uh or
participating in the market I think
they're only here because he put the
bill in if the bill hadn't come in if he
had introduced the bill they they we
never would have heard about this
problem okay well they wouldn't
they they would not put the bill in they
don't they I mean if theoretically if
they saw this being a big problem and
they hire a big time lobbyist he would
be running in here with this bill and
saying yeah this problem is huge you got
to take care of it but that's not what
happened you know he put the bill in and
and uh and so they all say well yeah we
agree yeah that's a good idea pass that
no I just don't pass things do we have
any idea if there are I could be the
minority I could be the only person in
this room
no no I just wonder are you aware of any
deleterious consequences or unintended
consequences in that that have
okay
so you're inclined to pass it is that of
my hearing
are you inclined to pass it or are you
inclined to maybe listen to well I don't
want to have to be put on this on the
commission uh we're doing a small pool
now
so I I just representative see this is
harmless
that passed in Maryland okay and that is
[Music]
vehicle and and that dealer walked me
through everything
on my car because he said there's
sensors and everything so we are native
not always so you're inclined that we
don't really need this legislation I
don't representative
okay
so
Gibbs is foreign
do you have something more you want to
offer representative Gibbs I I did um uh
I do in in reference to dealers walking
people through it I'd like to go back to
the point that I made earlier in the
hearing and that is that
um I recently found out that people are
now buying cars online and they don't
necessarily have a dealer to walk them
through it just as they may not any
longer have uh a manual for their new
car so some people may find out and
other people may not
okay so irrespective of the question of
fraud
which is a which is a a technical
question and a legal question
um are we aware of anybody who is
unhappy with the current state of
affairs because they were harmed as a
result
of the wrong glasses installed in their
vehicle
so we're gonna so if we're gonna enact a
statute more often than not we do so
because there's a problem
so in the final analysis here we have
you're correct when you use the term
prophylactic because but nobody has been
harmed nobody has complained absolutely
nobody has complained so we'd be making
a law
for a situation that doesn't even exist
we don't have to remediate we don't have
to remediate anything correct because
there's nothing to remediate
that am I you following me yes yes I'm
looking for a box I'm looking for a
bobble head here
it's great that everybody already had
this but for the benefit of those who
may be a little slower that's fine we
work this
sooner
you know my my in-laws are stuffers and
I'm a verbal processor so for the
benefit of any who are verbal processor
it's all been laid out there for you
thank you very much
somebody who doesn't Express themselves
verbally didn't yes didn't somebody come
to the sponsor and say this is a problem
no
this was something that happened to him
he had the phone call he was told on the
phone by no I I understood that part but
he also said that that wasn't and is he
still here evidently he left the room ah
well okay uh then maybe maybe I missed
one of us misunderstood him because what
I heard him say was this happened to me
but that wasn't why I brought the bill I
brought the bill because somebody else
came to me and told me about this
problem and I don't remember him saying
that
what he said was that this happened to
me and it could happen to somebody I
kept hearing they could but but I could
be wrong at any rate
none of this even matters because just
put passing this bill doesn't fix the
problem even if you did pass the bill it
doesn't fix the problem okay because
there are so many other there's so many
things I could not that can't get out
right all right so
um
representative gives has made a motion
of ought to pass is someone seconding
that motion who's on the subcommittee
seeing no seconding oh
okay you will okay
so uh the motion is ought to pass and
all those in favor please raise your
hand one two okay uh all those opposed
one two three four okay that motion
fails
um I move in expedient to legislate
do I have a second
thank you representative post any
discussion on itl
seeing none all those in favor of Rights
yell please raise your hand one two
three four
okay
all right okay so uh that takes care of
everything and
um now looking at the room I'm seeing a
lot of people here I think are all still
here for 1 30. so or yeah 1 30. so just
so you all know at this point 130 it
will be on the calendar next Wednesday
morning for a subcommittee and uh
potentially exact
Wednesday afternoon and at that time
Wednesday morning the insurance
department will tell us if there is a
dramatic if there's a fiscal impact to
patients with the amendment as we now
have
uh uh
um I just assumed put it off for a week
you know I I want I I appreciate your
your diligence on that
factor but
um at this point I think it's fine to to
put it off the next week
and then
172 we we're retaining that
we've already retained that one that's
the one that was the one that repeals
the whole thing
right
that was the one that's going to repeal
repeal the drug afford it and we we
decide to retain that
and you do have the amendment now Okay
so
certainly well the most important person
is the insurance department because they
they need to make a fiscal note on it
is that
okay
all right so we're we're all done until
1 15.
foreign
okay
so uh I guess
uh first we we have some uh guests today
active retirement Association and
Outreach function of the University of
New Hampshire division of continuing
education
welcome
um this is actually a fun committee to
be
yeah
because uh we usually get along pretty
well our unbiased opinion and uh
and I I said uh I've been my name is
John Hunt I've been serving on this
committee
um a long time I was first elected in 86
1886.
and uh my first term was science and
technology which you're actually sitting
on the science technology side of the
cootie Roman
um I couldn't get off that committee
fast enough and uh because
it was all anti-seabrook stuff but way
back then
and then but then there was this other
committee
um and that they seem to have a lot more
fun and uh because it was Interstate
banking was the big issue and they
seemed to have an event every week they
were at events and and um and so I said
well I want to get on that committee and
then in over the time over the years
this committee has expanded in terms of
its uh realm of issues so we picked up
liquor
and condos and trusts so we it's a
little bit of everything when it comes
to this committee so um it might be a
little hard to follow sometimes when we
jump from subject matter to subject
matter because we're going to go buy
Bill numbers but
um uh we do we we do have a method to
our Madness
Obsession and this is an exec session
which is very important because this is
the vote that the uh the house when the
house takes up action this will be the
vote that they will be ratifying which
is another one of those confusing things
when you see what happens on the house
floor because you're there you don't
vote up or down on a bill you vote on
based on the committee's recommendation
so we're going to be making a
recommendation and then it's taken up by
the house
so having said that uh House Bill 42
relative to the operation of certain
homeowners association
who's going to carry this bill forward
[Music]
what do we have here this one
we have just a straight
uh we have an amendment this one we have
an amendment right
yeah 0286h okay Rippers
to who wants to write the board now I
could write the blurb on everyone excuse
me the majority report but I really want
everybody to volunteer here now you want
to see some volunteering
pretty much 100 a year that you got you
here right all right okay
so the homeowners association who has a
condo what was it tell me is it do we
have any condom orders should we
okay
Okay so
do you like to make uh the right
recommendations I can help you out when
writing the blurbs but
okay
I'll I'll move I'll move on
exactly looking up the amendment when
you when I didn't hear you okay so I'm
really not ready to do that I'm sorry
okay
um so I'll move and and representative
Burroughs was second uh ought to pass on
the amendment number
0286 H
and this amendment
okay what did this amendment do is uh
yeah John you have the bill
okay
okay uh it does have my name on it so
um so what this is this is the issue of
of when you actually have a homeowners
association and someone wants to try to
um
uh end
the uh Association and
um that if the association was created
by their planning board if the planning
boards when they did the initial
development and they required an
association to be recreated this would
say that if you wanted to get rid of the
association uh you still had to go back
and get planning board approval
okay
all right uh any uh discussion on the
motion about to pass on the amendment
scene see none uh the clerk will call
the roll on ought to pass on amendment
number uh 0286h
Ammon yes
Osborne
petusic yes
yes Terry
yes
post yes
cool yes
Porcelli
nope
sellers yes yes
let me just Mark that okay
Paxton
Walsh yes
Burrows yes
Herbert yeah
oh yeah yes
am I clear
that clear yes
Vincent absent yeah
collabro yes
filio
yes
Gibbs yes
spear
yes
Sullivan yes
right and
um
Jim and Hunt yes
yes
19-0 okay the vote uh passed in 1907
um representative hunt seconded by
representative Bruce moves ought to pass
as amended is there any discussion on
the amendment seeing none the clerk will
call the role when she's ready
thank you
representative Ammon yes
Osborne
petusic yes Terry yes
post yes
Cole yes
pacelli yes nope no sellers
Paxton
Walsh yes Burrows yes
Herbert yeah
clerk yes
McAleer yes
it's an absent uh collabro yes
Tilia
yes
spear yes Sullivan
19-0 and Hunt yes oh sorry
chairman hunt okay all those in the vote
was 19-zip all those in favor are
placing on the consent Calendar please
say aye
aye those opposed you moved unanimously
I am
I guess
okay
House Bill 239 relative the condominium
disclosure of financial information
uh um I move that we retain 239.
and collabro second in the motion
okay any discussion on retaining
seeing none um do we have to do a roll
call
can we just say yeah
yeah retained first I think we did okay
you go we'll call it uh there's a vote
on retaining 239.
in the old days this chair could just
rule a bill would be retained and didn't
have to have a vote
all right some of some of the old rules
I like back
[Music]
representative Ammon yes
Osborne
too sick yeah Terry yes post yes Cole
yes
sellers yes Paxton yes Walsh yes Burrows
yes Herbert
Park yes
McAleer yes
collabro yes
billio yes
Gibbs yes
spear yes Sullivan yes and chairman hunt
yes
19-0 okay
great uh next is House Bill 86
related to the probe prohibiting the
state from Contracting with Chinese
government owned or Affiliated
technology manufacturers
chairman hunt did you want to send that
to the consent calendar oh no we don't
we retained don't go consent calendars
so whoops
so representative Spears would you like
to uh move to retain
House Bill 86 oh yes yes okay
all right the motion is to retain House
Bill 86 any discussion on the motion
anybody want to discuss it you need a
second
uh yeah sure
representarius seconding
okay yeah Spear and Terry sorry okay
okay
all right well thank you very much get
we'll get her next time okay all right
so the motion uh is to uh retain clerk
will call the roll
okay let me just put this all right
representative Ammon yes Osborne
petusic yes Terry
yes
post
yes Cole yes
sellers yes Paxton yes Walsh yes
Burrows
Herbert
your clerk nope
McAleer yes
collabro yes
phillio yes
Gibbs yes
spear yes
Sullivan yes
and chairman hunt yeah
yes
okay load is 18 to one
who's the one I'm the one
okay excuse me Mr chairman yes uh the
teacher in me prompts me to ask uh or to
wonder if you um might want to explain
to our continuing education students uh
what the effect of a retained motion is
okay
yeah so retaining means uh the bill
stays in committee does not go to the
house floor uh and uh we would then uh
come by the end of October of this year
uh the committee will then have to have
taken and will take action again
and at that time we can uh either pass
it or mend it work on it do something
with it and then it would come out on
the house floor the first week of
January
so I've always said that the most
exciting week on the lettuce if you want
to see the legislature in action is uh
that first week of January because that
means all those bills that didn't come
out of committee that were because of
whatever usually some controversy or
some a lot of discussion going on that
that then that excitement happens the
first week of January
oh I can't wait
you've been there done that before
actually the former chair with the
Democratic chair of this committee who's
not here anymore but he always used to
go to New York that week and I always
told us I said how can you go away the
most exciting week of the year right
there was his tradition to go to New
York okay House Bill 225 relative to
prohibiting the use of currency that
could be detrimental to privacy rights
okay
okay representative spear yes definitely
motion to retain mood to retain well
second and representative Cole seconds
all right
your sister retain yes
representative Ammon yes
Osborne
petusic yes Terry yes post yes Cole yes
sellers yes Paxton yes Walsh yes
sparrows yes Herbert
clerk yes McAleer yes
collabro yes
Helio yes Gibbs
yes spear yes Sullivan
and chairman hunt yes
yep 19-0
okay next up HB 227 relative to Fair
access to financial services
I would say that when we do all these
retained motions
um
there's another uh concept that people
say it's uh it's killing the bill gently
and that is the bill doesn't totally die
because it's still in the committee and
we still work on it but
um there is a there is a high
probability that some of these bills
come next January with the interim study
and so they never actually get out of
committee
okay
that's gonna happen
all right uh
yeah so who made the motion again
I'll make a motion to retain okay second
that representative macular
representative Terry makes the motion
retain
any discussion on the motion and it's my
understanding that there's an amendment
in process correct there there is some
talk about a potential Amendment another
reason to retain thank you
all right okay click we'll call the roll
Mr retain
each bill hb227
uh representative Ammon yes
Osborne
but too sick yes Terry yes post yes
Cole yes
sellers yes Paxton Walsh yes Burrows yes
Herbert yes
clerk yes macklier yes
collabro yes
philio no
Gibbs
yes
spear yes
television
and chairman hunt yes
yep okay HB 648 relative to establishing
a State Bank of New Hampshire
thank you
okay representative Ammon second and uh
representative spear
okay I saw her hand first sorry
All Right Moves In expedient to
legislate
and representative Ammons recognized to
speak to his motion
and thank you Mr chair um this bill has
been before this committee at least
seven times and every time the committee
has it yelled it um
my thinking is if
we don't want the state to run a
trucking company or any other type of
Industry we wouldn't want the state to
run a bank either so in that vein I
would uh move to itl
okay any more discussion on the motion
of any experience to legislate
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
representative Ammon yes
Osborne yes
Terry yes post yes oh
pacelli yes oh sorry sellers
Thaxton
Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert no
bullier yes
macklier
yes
collabro yes billio yes
spear yes Sullivan yes and chairman hunt
yes
18-1 uh are you all right putting this
on the consent calendar representative
Herbert
sure okay all those in favor of placing
on the consent Calendar please say aye
aye those opposed so moved unanimously
and Yemen joins the blur
you gonna do a manure report
not if he's doing it again put it on the
consent calendar okay oh yeah right
uh all right uh House Bill 520 relative
to Escrow accounts maintained by
licensed non-depository Mortgage Bankers
Brokers and services
okay uh representative hunt
uh I will move amendment number 0811
everybody got it
okay so this is the this bill uh is
um a request by the banking Department
to
um
revisit the statutory requirement of
banks who hold money uh it's it uh
usually taxes and insurance but taxes is
the major one that hold the banks that
hold it on your mortgage and you're
prepaying it and so then uh twice a year
they then write a check and pay for your
pay your tax bill
and the question that always comes up is
if you're if that money if you're paying
all that money into this account you
should be earning interest on that money
that's in the account uh the system
under the current statute who is a very
complicated convoluted and and
uncomfortable for everybody involved and
so uh we are now uh proposing that we're
using a new rate uh rate uh chart that's
actually put out by the FDIC
and uh and uh they have created a system
that is easy to reference what this
amendment does is remove the last line
in the bill that was proposed that had a
minimum and a cap on on what the
interest was
um especially since right now we're
starting to see caps start to to uh rise
because interest Insurance interest
rates are going up so we certainly
um uh would be doing everybody a
disservice and we didn't allow them to
take advantage of that escalating
interest that was available to them
um but over the last couple years
obviously uh for a fair amount of years
there hasn't been any interest at all
because uh the interest rates being so
low
so with that is there any more
discussion on this amendment
seeing none uh the clerk will call a
role on the amendment number 0811 yep
representative Ammon yes Osborne
petusic yes Terry yes post yes
Cole yes sellers yes
Paxton yes yes boss yes Burrows yes
Herbert
clerk yes yes mclear yes
collabro yes philio yes Gibbs yes spear
yes Sullivan
and chairman hunt
yes
okay pending motion now is
representative Ammon second in by
representative moves uh ought to pass as
amended
is there any discussion on the motion
okay
okay minority leader
all right uh
let me pull this one out
all right
representative Ammon yes representative
Osborne
petusic yes Terry yes post yes Cole yes
sellers yes Paxton
Walsh yes Burroughs yes Herbert yes
clerk yes mclear yes Vincent
whoops uh collabro yes Helio yes Gibbs
yes spear yes Sullivan
and chairman hunt
yes
19-0 okay
mentioned zip all those in favor of
placing House Bill 520 on the consent
Calendar please say aye
those opposed so moved unanimously
okay House Bill
522 relative to money transmitters
because
all right so who else is going to make a
blurb
make a motion ought to pass all right
actually
GP
and you're recognized speak to your
motion
okay so this bill
if I recall this is a request of the
banking Department
and it uh uh
I think it was it was a sort of
housekeeping
housekeeping on money transmitters
um and actually that's right it was
model legislation that all the banks all
the banking departments across the
country are passing and there was there
was another some more elements to it but
uh money transmitters
um are General is is if you might
remember Western Union
and uh but now we now we have other
people who do that kind of money
transfer like Walmart that's the one I
know uh who do the money transmitters
and this is just uh uh uh law that that
allows them they are licensed and
regulated by the banking Department
okay uh the motion is ought to pass
all set all right represent
representative Ammon yes Osborne
petusic
Terry yes post yes Cole yes sellers yes
Thaxton
Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert yes
clerk yes maclear yes
collabro yes phillio yes Gibbs
yes
spear yes
Sullivan
oops he left
and chairman hunt
yes
all right so maybe you got his job
offers already yeah
so it's 18-0
ought to pass 18. because he won he
walked out of the room okay all those in
favor placing 522 on the consent
Calendar please say aye those opposed
submitted unanimously
okay uh House Bill 595 related to the
oversight of the public deposit
investment pool
all right yes we have an amendment
um can I make a motion ought to pass
excellent who is that
night later cool
okay representative macular seconded by
representative Ammon moves ought to pass
on the amendment
number 0808 representative mcleodus
recognized speak to his motion
um this motion basically basically
removes the oversight of the investment
pool from the banking Department to the
treasury Treasurer's Department State
Treasurer right
goodbye
thanks for visiting us
sorry we're more exciting
okay
okay any discussion on the motion about
to pass on the amendment
okay clerk will call the roll
representative Ammon yes Osborne
Terry yes
post yes Cole yes sellers yes
Paxton
Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert yes
clerk yes McAleer yes
collabro yes billio yes
Gibbs yes
spear yes Sullivan
and chairman hunt yes 19-0 okay
so
that was Amendment representative
McAleer seconded by representative
Calabro moves ought to pass as amended
okay wait
okay
she seemed like she wanted to do it the
last time right and this is 583.
so GPA yeah
which is
all right hang on
foreign
all right okay clerk we'll call the roll
representative Ammon yes
uh Osborne petusic yes Terry yes
host yes call yes sellers yes Thaxton
yes Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert yes
clerk yes
maclier yes
Vincent nope collabro yes philio yes
Gibbs yes
spear yes Sullivan
and uh chairman hunt yes
okay
all those in favor placing on the
consent Calendar please say aye
aye those opposed so moved unanimously
okay next up uh
HP 584 related to the uniform commercial
codes article on controllable electronic
records
this one we're okay with right yeah
okay representative Ammon uh second by
representative patusek moves uh to pass
representative Ammons recognized to
speak to his motion
thank you Mr chair uh House Bill 584 is
a cleanup from a bill that was passed
last year House Bill 1503 and uh it it's
a polishing of you the uh Uniform
Commercial Code article 12 that deals
with digital assets
uh so-called controllable electronic
records that's how the UCC terms it and
this is a bill to get us up to the final
version of article 12 and it's uh if you
look through the bill it's an amendment
that is a lot of uh minor changes to
different sections
um just to bring us up to speed with the
final draft of the uniform law
commissions article 12 on digital assets
great
any discussion on the motion
seen none the clerk will call the roll
representative Ammon yes
Osborne
petusic Terry yes post yes Cole yep
sellers yes Paxton
Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert no
clerk yes mclear yes
collabro yes
filio yes
Gibbs yes spear
yes Sullivan
chairman hunt yes 18th one
do you know when all those in favor
placing on the consent Calendar please
say aye
those opposed
you want it on the regular calendar
I I usually do I'm sorry I didn't I was
skipping over that step
so you would like to leave it on the
consent calendar and put it on the yes
okay consent
all right
House Bill 645 relatively establishment
of decentralized autonomous organization
as legal entities within the state
representative Ammon has a motion I have
a motion
so um
the motion is to retain second by
representative Burroughs and I'd like to
speak to my motion
yes
so we could do this fast or we could do
it uh
we could do it right and uh in in recent
discussions including with attorney
Arden you're just at lunch today so just
about an hour ago this is an update we
would like to work on this over the
summer
and uh
my fear is that it takes a sense of
urgency and uh that a retain is death
With Dignity for a bill and I really
hope this isn't the case with this bill
because it's the very first
recommendation on the governor's crypto
uh commission cryptocurrency and digital
asset commission that we spent a year
developing so there's a lot of momentum
for this and uh I think retain is the
right way to go and instead of waiting
until next week to announce that I'd
like to do it today and uh you know for
respect from for the for the committee's
time so move to routine
okay any discussion on the motion to
retain
right
you have everybody knows my
mind yeah you have to turn your mic on
is it likely or is it under
consideration a little closer to the mic
if this were too
um the amendment were to pass and
and the bill to pass that we would find
ourselves establishing
a bank
or cryptocurrency
can I answer that absolutely so if you
use a dowel so
the The Entity would be a limited
liability Dao and that's what other
states are doing
um you would still have to apply for a
license if you were a bank
so you would still be subject to the
banking walls as a Dell just like you
would if you if you created an LLC you
would also have you know if you were
going to create a bank under an LLC or
some other corporate structure you'd
still be have to comply with the banking
regulations well my my question is
in other words I'm I'm taking that as a
yes it could be that hey uh Dow might uh
want to be involved in the banking
business
a dow could be involved in just about
anything a regular Corporation could be
involved in even uh private charity
or some kind of uh you know
not-for-profit purpose so anything that
a corporation uh might consider as part
of their mission a dow could also do
something similar provided that they
follow existing regulations for our
highly regulated Industries all right
insurance
I just want the public to know that uh
when I read
those and and also cryptos
desires to do banking transactions it is
quite likely that one of those one of
those Dallas is going to be a bank
okay representative Philip hello
uh we'll get there
uh I think it would be it's possible but
difficult for a dow to create a bank
that blockchain could create a ledger
and ledgers are a means of tracking
deposits deposits would be in the form
of a currency and currencies are what
governments issue
that's an ideal way to keep a ledger of
deposits and withdrawals would be in the
form of blockchain and blockchain would
actually be great for a ledger of
deposits and withdrawals because it's
immutable
what better way to keep track of your
money than something that could never be
changed like blockchain
but Banks work in currency and one
entity issues currency which is a
government the difficulty however would
be where do you store said currency if
you are
uh a Dao where you have no physical
existence if they can overcome that
difficulty then they may be able to do
so however given that we're moving
towards a digital economy I don't
actually hold any of the cash that I
have despite the fact that I actually
have money in my accounts I think that
that could be overcome now I think the
undertone may be are they going to work
in blockchain or the Bitcoin or other
cryptocurrencies
they could given that those are a form
of security get but they could work in
any form of security they could decide
that they want to trade in Coca-Cola or
anything else that's traded on the NYSE
if they were to get a license as a
Securities broker
they can do anything under the sun just
as anybody can do anything under the sun
you can do good things you can do bad
things it's up to you as an individual
we hope that they do good sometimes
people do bad things that's their fault
and then we go after them and the state
has that power
yeah that's great yeah but I would say
in just a to having a little experience
with the banking statute
um that there are some other
requirements of thresholds today would
have to overcome that would be somewhat
complicated for instance uh the banking
department requires you to you if you
get a license to to be a bank you have
to have a physical location and so they
can go audit your business and so the
books have to be audible so there will
be a lot of uh threshold uh things that
they would have to you know to
I correct that also to have a bank you'd
also need to have a certain amount in
your initial assets to be a bank which
is going to be pretty difficult for many
organizations to overcome in the first
place because you need to have insurable
assets right you know and and we talk
about depository Banks
so yeah and you've got to have actual
real dollars behind it to to open up the
bank so I still have concerns in that
regard starting with the fact that uh
monetary Sovereign Nation it's it's one
nation one money and if we have a
situation where we have a private
private currency that's being being
that that's my concern and I'm okay that
is fine we appreciate that you are
willing to share us why you have
concerns
so one interesting thing to consider
about a dow that operates on a
blockchain in smart contracts is the the
activity of the Dow is
open to the public and it's auditable
and it's uh in a format where the code
can be reviewed the transactions can be
reviewed that's different than a private
organization so
this the spirit of 645 is to leverage
that transparency so that we have uh you
know we can weed out the Bad actors by
having lots of eyeballs on that activity
that that is open to the public so it's
a little bit different than a a private
company that has the book secret the
decision making is secret and so we want
to facilitate that because sunlight is
the best disinfectant so and that would
be their marketing right marketing
approach okay the motion is to retain
any more discussion on the motion seen
on the clerk will call the roll
representative Ammon yes
Osborne
petusic yes
Terry yes post yes Paul yes
yes sellers yes Thaxton
Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert no
clerk no
maclier yes
collabro yes paleo yes
Gibbs yes it's Pierre yes Sullivan
uh chairman hunt yes
Seventeen two yep right okay about 17-2
all right house bill 173 relative to
toilet facilities provided by
restaurants
this is another retainer
no this is retained because this this
bill
this bill he wanted us to he wanted us
actually to repeal the law the guy from
the bill the bill he wanted us to repeal
it but not yet until they've approved
the Knicks round of Boca
um and then and then then we'll get to
repeal it so we'll hold on to it and
this will come out in January with a uh
an amendment that will repeal the whole
statute altogether
okay so I guess I would put that under
my name okay
and Burrows
okay
right and this is two to retain
emotions clear
clerk will call the roll
representative Ammon yes Osborne
petusic yes Terry yes post yes Cole yes
sellers yes Paxton
Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert
yes Clark yes
maclier yes
collabro yes
philio yes dibs
spear
Sullivan
hunt yes 19-0
okay House Bill 242 relative to Banning
pfas in food is this on consent yes it's
retaining
in food packaging
yep
okay representative McAleer
and this is pending on some
pardon me a second um okay
okay
um the retain is due to the fact that
the federal government is expected to
come out with some sort of a statement
on pfas and I think we should hold off
and uh until we hear what they have to
say thank you
okay any more discussion on the motion
to retain
see none the clerk will call the roll
when she's ready
representative yes
Terry yes post yes Cole yes
sellers yes yes
Burrows yes Herbert
reluctantly yes
Clark yes mclear yes
collabro
yes Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan
chairman hunt yes
19-0
okay
House Bill 280 relevant to the sale of
freeze-dried food
representative petusic
by representative Burroughs moves any
speeding to legislate
representative patusek is recognized
speak to his motion
I put this into a constituent of mine
and after discussions with her she
decided not to move forward with it so
that's why we moved RTL
okay
any discussion on the motion seeing none
I have a question oh
representative Herbert despite the fact
that we're going to do what you want to
do the uh it still is allowable that
somebody on doing it on a farmer's
market or a something like that level
that's being a certified kitchen and yes
that's good the answer to your question
is no they they need to be licensed as a
certified kitchen
yes virtual kitchen if you're going to
sell it if you're going to give away
freeze-dried food for free unless you
why
if you live in the 10 towns that have
kind of of code that will allow them to
have those commercial kitchens in their
own homes
you may do that otherwise it has to be
in a commercial kitchen if you don't
live in those 10 Towns
no big well let's just say the state law
which is what we deal with we don't
state law right now requires that if you
want to sell
a food product
a commit kitchen that has been approved
uh by the HHS okay I just yeah I just
thought you know
it would make a good small business if
somebody wanted to do it and could put
the money up I just that's my only
concern that we kind of squelched no
it's unsafe
elsewhere
okay
okay so the motion is index being to
legislate any more discussion on the
motion
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
representative Ammon yes Osborne
you're too sick yes Terry yes post yes
Cole yes
sellers yes Thaxton
Walsh yes Burrows
Herbert yes
Clark yes macalea yes
collabro yes Emilio
Gibbs yes spear
yes
Sullivan
chairman yes
17-2 72.
um those two are you have a problem with
putting this on the consent calendar
okay all those in favor replaced me on
the consent calendar please
um if he's missing how could it be 17-2
oh it must be 16 16. thank you
must be on ways and means
okay
all right uh all those in favor consent
Calendar please say aye those opposed so
moved unanimously
okay House Bill 248 relative to revenue
from commemorative bottles of liquor I
will move
ought to pass
and
represent Calabro would second it I'll
second it
it's already seconded
collabro all right got it okay
uh so this is uh just the fund in which
uh when we sell these wonderful uh
commemorative
bottles that are
great for collecting it's not so great
for drinking but
it just did
but uh
um the the good news is uh that um now
that I'm on the historic committee that
I've convinced the commission to see if
they can find somebody in New Hampshire
who will do these going forward because
they've been using the same guy in
Massachusetts for too long so but
otherwise the money goes into a fund and
then we distribute the money and it's a
major the suspense is to maintain the
Hall of flags
any more discussion on the motion about
to pass
seeing none the clerk will call the rule
on 248 and representative Ammon yes
Osborne
but Tuesday yes Terry yes post yes
cool
sellers yes baxton
Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert yes Clark
yes
McAleer yes collabro
filio yes
Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan
and chairman hunt yes
all right
so 19-0
yeah 19 is it all those in place for
placing 248 on the consent Calendar
please say aye
aye those opposed so moved unanimously
uh HB 407 regular related to
regulations on alcohol uh I move uh uh
to pass on the amendment
number 0780
you better get a second my motion
awesome
and this is just housekeeping this is uh
yes I will be recognized to speak to my
emotion all right
this is housekeeping uh this is a has
several different parts of the bill and
it's just different pieces in the liquor
statute that are updating and making
current and
um
foreign
nothing too controversial
first vote will be on the amendment okay
yeah so uh it's any more discussion on
the motion about to pass on the
amendment seeing none the clerk will
call the roll
s
all right representative Ammon yes
Osborne
petusic yes Terry yes post yes Cole yes
yes sellers yes Paxton
Walsh yes
Burrows yes Herbert yes
clerk yes
maclier yes
collabro yes
philio yes Gibbs yes spear
yes Sullivan yeah and chairman hunt yes
19-0 okay uh I move
uh uh 407
ought to pass as amended seconded by
representative patusek
any discussion on the motion about to
pass this amended
see none the clerk will call the roll
all right representative Ammon yes
Osborne
petusic yes Terry yes post yes Cole yes
sellers yes Paxton
Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert yes
clerk yes McAleer yes
collabro yes phillio yes Gibbs yes spear
yes Sullivan yes and chairman hunt yes
19-0
okay
um all those in favor placing on the
consent Calendar please say aye
aye those opposed submoved unanimously
okay House Bill 544 legalizing cannabis
for retail sale
um
representative filio second by
representative hunt moves to retain
5 44.
and representative Philly I was
recognized to speak to his motion
this uh Bill sought to legalize cannabis
in the state as overseen by The Liquor
Commission however we've had another
bill that has come to this committee and
has now been passed to the house which
sought to do the same thing and has a
bipartisan support
uh retaining this bill would allow us to
take a wait and see approach and then
pass this bill next year potentially if
the the current bill were to fail either
in the house or elsewhere so I think
taking this would allow us to get a
second bite of the Apple if we need to
do so
excellent
any more discussion on the motion to
retain Representatives would you like to
weigh in yes I would I'd like to make a
motion to itl this we have a pending
motion so all right
you can speak okay
you can speak against the pending motion
all right I'd like to speak against it
and uh as an esteemed colleague had said
previously if we don't want the state
having control over bank I don't think
we should have the state controlling an
illegal drug if the federal government
is important enough as to what their
opinion is for pfas I would think it's
also important that they have not
legalized cannabis
federally
fair enough any other discussion on the
motion to retain
see none of the clerk will call the roll
representative Ammon yes
Osborne
but too sick
Terry no
post yes
Cole
sellers yes
Paxton
Walsh no
boroughs
Herbert yes clerk yes McAleer yes
collabro yes philio yes yes
Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan
chairman hunt yes
so it's
it's 16 to three
okay House Bill 613 relative to the
regulation of individual health
insurance Market under RSA 404g
uh
this is probably under my name right
okay
yeah okay yeah so I I move on to pass
second and by representative patusek
and this is a uh housekeeping measure on
from the insurance department related to
the statutory of 404g
any discussion on the motion about to
pass
okay I'm saying none the clerk will call
the roll
representative Ammon
yes
Osborne
for Tuesday yes Terry yes post yes cool
yes
sellers yes Paxton
Walsh yes sparrows yes Herbert yes
clerk yes maclear yes
collabro yes
Helio yes
Gibbs yes spear yes
Sullivan
and chairman hunt yes 19-0
all those in favor putting 613 on the
consent Calendar please say aye aye
those opposed
to move unanimously
okay
HB 303 relative to insurance covered for
Pain Management Services
okay this is a retaining who like to
make the motion representative Burroughs
seconded by representative patusek moves
to retain
and representative Burroughs is
recognized to speak to an emotion
um yes I think that um on 353 correct
this is
um
pain management
yeah I would love to retain
um I think that um this bill is too
broad and I think that um this is a this
is an important subject but this bill is
trying to do too much and we need to
narrow it down
okay
is the question clear
to retain to retain clerk will call the
roll
representative Ammon yes Osborne
petusic yes Terry yes post yes Cole yes
sellers yes Saxton
Walsh yes sparrows yes
Herbert yes
clerk yes macalear yes
collabro yes billio yes Gibbs yes it's
Peter yes Sullivan
chairman hunt yes 19-0
okay
House Bill 414 relative to health
insurance coverage for preventative pfas
care
uh we're gonna retain this representing
Calabro would you would be
representative Calabro we're doing 414
you want to make you make the motion to
uh retain this one
okay second by representative patusek
any discussion on the motion to retain
see none
clerk will call the roll
representative Ammon yes Osborne petusic
Terry yes post
yes
Paul yes
sellers yes Thaxton
Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert yes Clark
yes McAleer yes
collabro
filio
yes Gibbs yes spear yes
Sullivan
chairman hunt yes 19-0
okay
House Bill 319 establishing Community
studying and all payers system of
insurance for Hospital services
uh I'll move to retain second
any discussion on the motion to retain
just just 400 affiliate
I'd move that we would ought to pass
this uh motion this bill because it
merely cease to create a study committee
for an all-pare system as we've seen
from Maryland an all-payer system could
reduce the cost of Health Care in the
state
while that may not work in New Hampshire
a committee would simply seek to
determine whether it would or not and
whether what the New Hampshire way would
be for doing this it would create a
bipartisan committee to study this and
there's no loss in creating a study to
determine if this would work in New
Hampshire or not yeah the problem is a I
don't know there could be bipartisan
because you're you have one you have one
senator
and four is it four representatives and
then you get all these other people who
are being appointed we have no idea what
their political persuasion is so the
idea is and I'm committed to uh finding
someone who is an expert on their system
and have them come in and speak to the
committee and just be with this
committee rather than having the
governor and the speaker and all these
other appointments when when when the
idea is just to be educated about what
it is so I think it's worthwhile to just
keep it within the committee
Mr chairman we also heard testimony
that um these systems were being passed
or had implemented in other states but
we don't really have any solid evidence
that effect so no it's just Maryland
there's more work that needs to be done
on this thank you what's up okay
so motion clear to retain
all right clerk may call the roll
representative Ammon yes
Osborne
batusic yes
Terry yes
post yes
Cole yes
sellers yes Saxton yes
yes Walsh yes Burrows yes
Herbert no
clerk no backlier yes
collabro yeah
Helio no
Gibbs yes
spear
yes
Sullivan
and chairman hunt yes
all right sixteen three
perfect
okay
all right next up House Bill 353
establishing an interstate compact for
Universal Health Care
okay
no I think that's when we're gonna itl
no
I thought this was itl
committee
it is
we were okay okay
my notes say we have I tailed it oh this
is us this year is it this is this is
the committee that this is runs on the
idea that you're going to create find a
a health plan
that has the same mandates the same
requirements the same everything same
same same and that you're going to find
multiple states that are going to have
that same thing so I can tell you you
know on on the face of this is that just
in our New England states each of us
have different mandates we have written
our mandates differently so to get all
the New England states to all come up
with the same mandate so just the same
language the same requirements
um it's impossible
Mr chairman
this is House Bill 353 my notes from
yesterday say it was retained earlier
all right if you want to retain it who
seconded it
we exec this previously it was
subcommitting right that's a
recommendation okay so the
recommendation was to retain right now
so now we're dealing with this is the
full committee okay all right that's
fine
I'll make a motion to retain okay okay
that's fine
that's fine that's fine beer
return just beer made the motion
yeah but he could thank you okay all
right now we're ready to go all right
everybody so the motion is to retain
the doors locked
clerk call the roll what's next all
right this is on
hb353fm yes retain all right
representative Ammon yes
Osborne
petusic yes
Terry yes post yes
cool
sellers yes Paxton
Walsh yes arrows
Herbert yes
sir yes mclear yes
collabro
Helio
yes
Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan
and chairman hunt
all right yes
19 to zero
okay
all right house bill 389 relative to
Consumer Protection relating to hospital
price transparency
no this is the one I have is itl yes
yes one of these has got to be Ito
representative
I moved to itl uh House Bill 389 while
it has a good intent the bill as written
is both ambiguous and unenforceable all
right
okay representative filio seconded by
representative hunt moves in expedient
to legislate
okay
any discussion on the motion of innings
meeting to legislate
all right clerk will call the roll okay
representative Ammon
yes
Osborne
petusic yes Terry yes post yes Cole yes
sellers yes Paxton Walsh yes Burroughs
yes Herbert yes
clerk yes macalea yes
collabro yes
pilio yes Gibbs no
spear yes
Sullivan
and German hunt yes
18th one eighteen to one uh
representative Gibbs you're okay with
putting this on the consent calendar I'm
okay with it okay all those in favor
placing the consent please say aye aye
those opposed so moved unanimously
You're Gonna Write the blur right yeah
cool
yeah okay
um House Bill 130 we're going to uh have
a subcommittee next Wednesday morning
and we'll execute Wednesday afternoon
um
and
these are connected 131.72 that's enough
okay House Bill 172 relative to
investigating potential redundancies
between the prescription drug
affordability board and existing state
agency programs related regarding
prescription drug cost data
right yeah so this one we're going to
retain question
yes is this one related
yes
okay yeah
yeah so 130
130 was to repeal the whole damn thing
and and the 172 was to study uh whether
that was it doesn't really work
so right now we're doing uh 172 and
we're just retaining 172.
okay
any discussion of the motion to retain
172.
C9 clerk will call the roll
representative Ammon yes
Osborne petusic yes Terry yes post yes
Cole yes
sellers yes Paxton walls yes Burrows yes
Herbert yes clerk yes maclier yes
collabro yes philio yes Gibbs yes spear
yes Sullivan
and chairman hunt yes 19-0
okay
all right house bill 383 relative to
provider contract standards for pharmacy
benefit managers
this is a retain
okay so I move to retain
second
okay any discussion on the motion
I have a question yes
um
if I know anything about
benefits managers
uh being able to find out how they come
up with their pricing is damn near
impossible
so uh I can see the the need to do it
but I don't uh
I haven't heard anything now yet that
would give me the return of confidence
that we would actually get to the main
meal
thank you okay so you're suggested we
should kill this bill yeah okay so this
bill is actually it's it's a it's sort
of a misnomer in terms of the standard
for pharmacy benefit managers what this
is is that if you're a independent
pharmacist
and you have decided that you want to
keep all your customers because you're
in a small town and you don't want them
to go mail order you don't want them to
go travel to one of those big overpriced
well let's say the pharmacy that's way
in the back of the store and you have to
go buy through all that groceries to get
there
so you're uh and the irritation by these
independent pharmacists is that when it
comes time to get reimbursed their
reimbursement is uh is lower than their
actual cost because they were not in the
network and not getting that same
pricing and so this was the I think
there was something in the bill about
this minimum price level and some some
bizarre description like that and that
um and so the idea was that uh they that
if if the PBM can actually find it at a
cheap node that is in a cheaper price
that they would pass that information on
to the pharmacist which probably won't
be much good because the pharmacist
really can't do business with that
wholesaler because they don't do enough
volume
so that is what the issue of this bill
is about and certainly it's going to
take some head scratching to figure out
how we're going to solve this problem
okay
okay about 383 and it sounded to me like
you were talking about 426.
no I'm talking about 383. the pharmacist
in charge is a whole another another
that's actually a bigger Pharmacy
problem it's not that's not the
independent pharmacist
okay 383 is the problem I just described
okay so the motion is to retain
all right question clear clerk will call
the roll
representative Ammon yes
Osborne petusic
Terry yes post yes
Cole yeah sellers yes Thaxton
Walsh yes Burrows yeah Herbert yes click
yes
maclear yes
collabro yes philio yes Gibbs yes spear
yes Sullivan
uh chairman hunt yes 19-0
okay
all right house bill 426 relative
regulation affirm assists in charge and
pharmacies and representative Calabro
seconded by representative hunt moves uh
ought to pass in 426 and
there you go and who yeah she's gonna
she's gonna make the motion I'm gonna
have her because she cares about this
bill
and then I will second it okay and uh
you will speak to your motion
microphone Mike please
thanks
I am trying to remember this this is
this is the one that that the the
you might have other firms you know
who's the who's the actual Pharmacy in
charge because you you're you're a big
chain and you have
the the pharmacist in charge is actually
not the real pharmacist of that yes that
Right Aid this was the cleanup pillars
CVS and so basically it's uh the the the
pers the pharmacist in charge is whoever
happens Beyond Duty that day I remember
everything
him
out of my mouth or put them there any
other discussion on the motion about to
pass on 426
there was no Amendment right yeah
yeah okay any other discussion on the
motion seeing on the clerk will call the
roll
on 4 26.
representative Ammon yes Osborne
petusic yes Terry yes post yes Cole yes
yes sellers yes Paxton yes Walsh yes
Burrows yes Herbert
clerk yes mclear yes collabro yes philio
yes Gibbs yes spear yes
Sullivan yes
uh chairman yes 19-0
okay all those in favor placing 426 on
the consent Calendar please say aye aye
aye those opposed
so moved unanimously
page two
the end is in sight
okay uh House Bill 513 relative to the
affordability and safety of clinician
administered drugs
so this is the one we have an amendment
for but we are going to schedule this
for next Wednesday in the morning
and execut Wednesday afternoon
um
so just be aware this is the the bill
that um
the hospital Association wishes we
didn't have
put it put it lightly
okay
um can we exactly
as well as I mean after hearing but wait
until the afternoon uh it's going to be
a
pretty long lunch
or it could be well I would schedule a
10. um
yeah I guess we could we I'll try to do
11. yeah so we'll we'll subcommittee at
10 in in executive 11.
right
okay
uh next up is uh House Bill 479 related
to Administrative Hearings
augmentation of electronic notices to
Insurance licensees Insurance producer
activities
this has got to be my bill
are we infinite that's right we'll we'll
got into carrying all these ones
okay
no I'll take care of it okay so uh I'm
uh I move and and Ammon seconds
um and it was a
did this have a this has an amendment
right
yeah
what's the number 0206
don't worry about the H because it just
means house okay
um
this amendment
okay this this amendment actually came
in when the bill was introduced by the
insurance department
right
and
clarified their language
I can't help you with any of that
that's too much baby okay here it is I
got it now
okay
everybody should have it uh the
commissioner shall provide notice to the
insurer to the electronic means as
specified by the commissioner the note
shall be is this the one with the
internet
you've been given they still yes okay
okay
all right
yeah
on the amendment
0206 all right okay question clear
that's what I can call the rule
oops here we go
um representative Ammon yes Osborne
petusic yes Terry
yes host yes Cole yes
yes sellers yes Paxton Walsh yes
sparrows yes Herbert yeah
clerk yes
McAleer yes Vince uh collabro yes filio
yes Gibbs yes spear
yes Sullivan
chairman Hut yes 19-0
thank you
okay on the amendment okay all right so
representative uh hunt
seconded by represent Ammon moves ought
to pass as amended
um
question clear
clerk will call the roll
when she's ready
representative Ammon yeah
Osborne
petusic Terry yes
post yes Cole yes
sellers yes Paxton yes yes Walsh yes
Burrows yes Herbert yes
Clark yes macklier yes collabro yes
billio yes Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan
and German hunt yes 19-0 ought to pass
as amended all those in favor pointing
on the consent Calendar please say aye
those opposed so moved unanimously
I'll spill 210 relative to in fire
insurance contracts
uh uh is this on consent only if there's
one is this going to be on consent oh
that's all right 479 all those in favor
of consent please say aye
aye yeah those opposed yes sorry
all right 210
and just OTP
anybody wanna
anybody want to do it
okay I like writing blurbs
just sometimes I think it you know
people say
all they see is my name there
a little awkward but okay
um so this one
was it was it wasn't too
struck out either on and unspecified
basis right
it just it was it was really
housekeeping it was it was one
what was the what was the story behind
it
what was the insurance department what
was the story behind this one
say it again
just clarifying the statute okay
I'll I'll I'll call will again a little
bit more bones to that one okay but it
was it was the statue wasn't clear to
what the intent was
redundancy it says it twice the same
thing twice oh even better okay
you could say say more with less words
perfect okay
any more any discussion
uh
who's second it but two SEC but two SEC
[Music]
representative Ammon yes Osborne petusic
Terry yes post yes Cole
sellers yes Thaxton yes Walsh yes
Burrows yes Herbert yes clerk yes
macklier yes
collabro yes
philio yes
Gibbs yes
it's Pierre yes Sullivan
chairman hunt yes 19-0
okay all those in favor replacing HP 210
on the consent Calendar please say aye
those opposed
so it moved unanimously
House Bill 249 establishing regulatory
standards for pet insurance industry
we have yes
on the amendment
okay representative Burroughs seconded
by representative billio
ought to pass on the amendment and
representative and what's the number of
the amendments
got it and representative Rose is
recognized to speak to her motion
you might want to put your mic on
yeah I'd like to pass the amendment um
it was just fixing a mistake in terms of
uh
um pet owners being allowed to bring
their their pooches into the
establishment with the stipu although
the dog would have to be leave if a
service dog came in and it would also
enable dogs to come out on the patio so
they wouldn't have to sit in hot cars
this is truly a pooch Bill wait a minute
it's a future wait a minute I need some
more sheets
just when we're getting to the end here
okay
all right you got a good dog joke so we
just got a puppy a year ago and I named
him Moby Moby
and when I walk him people say did you
name him after the singer
and I say no I named him after the dick
Moby Dick
and it's just a funny little joke
oh God
[Laughter]
um
all right so this is on the amendment
0750 and I told the speaker that I would
get this done in less than two hours
[Laughter]
two hours
yeah no I think we're I think we can
make it all right all right you got your
body cheats all right here we go the
question is on the amendment right
representative Ammon yes Osborne
batusic Terry yes post yes call yes yes
sellers yes Saxton
Walsh yes Burrows yes perfect yes clerk
yes mclear yep
collabro yes phillio yes
Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan yeah and
chairman hunt yes
19-0 on the amendment great uh the
motion now is uh ought to pass as
amended
um so just so everybody remembers this
what this bill does is to
um
take a model legislation for the pet
industry so that it's a uniform Bill uh
what what is covered in terms of someone
is buying pet insurance
um and the department would very much
want to make sure that uh when people do
this business that they can enforce it
by they'll have a standard policy or
standard policy requirements so they can
ensure that the person can shop it
around fairly
uh move by yourself
oh okay sure who is the Prime sponsor of
this bill
this is okay so pearls and uh yeah okay
girls you want to do the blurb sure okay
representative Bros and seconded by uh
okay good
octopass has amended on hb249
representative Ammon
yes Osborne no
batusic yeah
Terry
yes
post yes call yes
um sellers
yes
Paxton Walsh yes sparrows yes Herbert
clerk yes McAleer yes
collabro yes
yes Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan yes
and chairman hunt yes 18 to one
okay
all those in favor placing on the
consent Calendar please say aye
are those opposed
so moved unanimously
last but not least
HB 304 relative to Advanced Driver
assistance systems Disclosure by auto
glass repair or replacement facilities I
make a motion Ito second spear second
that was fast
all right
ready to vote
okay moves uh in expedient to legislate
and recommend a sphere representative
Spears recognize you speak to her motion
uh this this bill was to uh require a
law actually that if a windshield was
replaced on a car that had driver
assistance for uh
speed or some other collision avoidance
system that they might have that they
would be told that the
repair facility had to tell them whether
or not they could calibrate the the
the the the the the camera that's on the
front windshield
uh the problem with it once this there's
a number of problems with it but
replacing I mean calibrating the camera
can be the result of much more than just
replacing the glass that can be the
result of uh driving on through a
pothole there's a there's a number of
things so it just got bigger and bigger
and bigger and so it just became
unwieldy yes unwielded it would be
inexperienced
and experience yes
dude
okay any other discussion on the motion
of inexperienced to legislate on House
Bill 304.
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
all right representative Ammon yes
Osborne
so too sick yes Terry yep post yes Cole
yes
sellers yes Thaxton yes boss yes Burrows
yes Herbert yes clerk yes maclier
yes
Vincent nope collabro yes phillio yes
Gibbs
spear
Sullivan
chairman hunt yes 18-1
okay 18-1
and are you all right putting this on
the consent calendar representative
okay all those in favor please another
consent Calendar please say aye aye
those opposed so moved unanimously
so people will say Commerce Community
doesn't do anything
okay thank you guys so much I am you
know I can't tell you how pleased I am
that we got through this and efficiently
and I realized that some might say we
just kicked a very large can down
the road uh maybe the size of an oil can
but we've kicked again but I I have a
full faith that by the time we get get
to these bills and come October we'll
have a better resolution rather than
just uh keep kicking the can but you
never know so thank you all and we'll
see you next Wednesday at 10 A.M we'll
we'll sub the two bills and then exec
them
on Wednesday morning
okay
and have a
so with the two bills we have is that we
have 130
and 5 13.
130 is the uh PBM to deal with the PBM
uh